for lunch everyone uh so uh this
afternoon session uh first speaker is
going to be a
long-time friend a
colleague from uc davis uh greg
cooperberg
[Music]
okay
uh
thanks super much for inviting me um
this this won't be
uh
i i feel a little funny following the
the fantastic talks of the morning my my
my talk is not
not is is maybe not quite as newsworthy
as this but but it's still interesting
material but in fact i discovered one
thing
i
i had been thinking for a long time that
theoretical computer scientists are
basically mathematicians after all you
proved theorems but i actually learned
that
there's an essential difference and an
easy way to tell
if
if
if it's a computer if it's a
mathematician then they use beamer if
it's a computer scientist then they use
powerpoint
and if you if you use the other one you
know you should maybe you know
maybe con consider changing your
credentials because it's clearly a
variance from the
operative criterion um
so so that's that's okay so this kind of
reveals which one i am doesn't it now
um
here's another way to
tell something if
if if there's a commutative diagram
probably a mathematician
[Music]
so
my talk is about the hidden subgroup
problem which which is which has been
there for decades and and you probably
kind of know what
what it is but here here are the rules
of the game just for context uh suppose
you have a discrete group g
and uh you have you have a group g and
what i mean is a a computational group
you have a completely healthy
computational model you need unique
names for group elements fast algorithms
for group operations all that jazz
and x is an unstructured set
and then at this function f up here it's
called a hiding function and
it can be computed in polynomial time
then
h is
called a hidden subgroup
if
what this
diagram means is that f is h periodic
and otherwise one to one
so in other words
values of f uh agree if and only if
the inputs x and y differ by an element
of h
okay
and now since this is an oracular
problem the healthy way to parameterize
the
the
complexity of an algorithm
for the hidden subgroup problem
is is in terms of the bit complexity of
the output rather than the input so the
the input is an oracle or even if you
have an explicit input it's an it's it's
it's an unstable parameterization but
you can say polynomial time in the in
the complexity of the output
so uh
the
the original the the really important uh
thing that started the whole concept of
the hidden subgroup problem which has
been important since then
take g to be z to the k
so this will be additive rather than
multiplicative because it's a billion
but that's fine
and suppose that the hidden subgroup h
has finite index in other words it's has
rank k
okay
then
the theorem of schwann coteau is that
you can calculate h in quantum
polynomial time
or in lingo in fbqp functional b can be
uniformly in the dimension k and the bit
complexity of a description of h and it
would be something like uh
the bit complex total bit complexity of
of a lattice basis of age
so
this
huge theorem this is now
ancient history for this field but i'll
go ahead and say it is that you get
a generalized discrete logarithm result
as well as a cardinality result
given uh
an algorithmic finite b in group a
then
you can learn its isomorphism type in
explicit form as an ability group and
not only that you get a quantum
polynomial time algorithm to compute the
discrete logarithm map from the from the
general algebraic a
which may be cryptographically difficult
at least for a classical computer to its
standard form
using using uh using a finite group
basis like that okay
and this has tons of applications in
both algorithmic number theory and
public key cryptography
now
after this
after this rather dramatic beginning or
almost beginning because there was first
simon's algorithm
most of the discussion in most of the
algorithms for the hidden sub root
problem other than shortcut since then
have assumed that the ambient group the
the domain of the hiding function is
finite
so here's just a roster of various
results
uh there's the disclaimer it's not
complete
so there's a result
if
if g is finite and h is normal this
result if g is finite and almost a
billion
you can take a heisen group a finite
heisenberg group or z mod p
you can take g finite and two stealth
bilbotant that's a generalization of the
heisenberg case
there's the dihedral case which was
where there's work
by uh me and odregovin and chris pikert
and some other cases
you have this pollen this very
interesting polynomial query complexity
for any finite group which sounds like a
strong
super
general thing except notice g is finite
and still you have a
an important discussion it still looks
intractable when g is the symmetric
group
but still g is finite in that case and
in any case that's another topic
so
uh the the motivation for the for my
still incomplete paper i certainly hope
i get to find the time to finish it but
it has several parts
uh is to just look again at what happens
when g is an infinite group
and uh
this is one of the sort of juicy results
that that i found
not a breakthrough but still kind of
cool
which is that you don't necessarily get
the good news from schwarz algorithm you
can really get evidence to the contrary
in fact conditionally prove that you
can't do it
for example
let g be the rational numbers
as a discrete group i i don't mean the
topological version which has been
looked at by
by uh by sean hallgren and and uh
kirsten over there and and song and
others but just just the rational
numbers is a discrete group with the
standard encoding of the rational
numbers
and actually
certainly in the infinite case you you
have to think about not only what the
group is but how it's encoded
then
the hidden sub-group problem is
np-hard yeah
what is the standard encoding
you write the numerator in binary or
decimal and then a slash and then the
denominator
and a minus sign in front
okay
are you going to give an intuition is
this going to be for reasons of related
to subset song
so
uh
i was going to mainly talk about the
positive result but this one is fun
enough that i can talk about it i can
talk about it more at the end but just
briefly now
you can
first of all
re-express the whole model of np
where the the witnesses or candidate
witnesses are prime numbers candidate
witnesses some prime numbers are
accepted others are rejected by the
predicate
and so then you you make a hidden
subgroup
using the reciprocals of the accepted
uh uh witnesses
okay
um and then uh you can make a hiding
function
on the rational numbers
using only a predicate that tells you
whether a prime is good or bad
okay
so that if
uh there are no accepted witnesses the
hidden subgroup is the integers
and if there are accepted witnesses then
the hidden subgroup is bigger than the
integers
and
and that doesn't require factoring the
irrational number you're given oh i
cheated a little bit
uh
when i said np hard i mean
either relative to pqp
that's fair
or with a factoring or
but actually actually it's not so bad
then the result is otherwise
unconditional
if you're you can use partial
factorizations
using only that part of factorization
uh
that you can do in classical polynomial
time using the pollard
p minus one algorithm but then you need
a
a conjecture and number theory that in
the that there's enough supply of
potential predicates
of sorry potential with witnesses
all right
okay
now this one to make you happy
it's completely unconditional
okay
and it's a classical reduction
if g is a non-abelian free group
using word encoding of elements
then
hidden sub root problem is np hard even
for normal subgroups
contra the algorithm for the normal
hidden subgroup problem
when when the group is finite
now to emphasize encoding uh
suppose that g is z to the k
with
unary vector encoding
um
su in other words pseudopolynomial query
cost
you the billing for a query
is is
grows with is say polynomial in the norm
of the input vector rather than the bit
complexity of the input vector
then the hidden sub problem
defined in a fair way is as hard as uh
as unique short lattice spectrum
so after getting the what i thought was
going to be the paper with with these
with this kind of rebuttal results here
here you go this this you didn't expect
hard things to happen here here we are
and i was just going to put in the
introduction
this is you know especially the third
one but actually both the second
actually all of them
in contrast to shortcuttaea which i
thought
completely solves either the k with
standard binary encoding of vectors
but then i thought okay well if we're
going to cite that i better i better go
over the papers on this to make sure and
then i notice the finite index
hypothesis and i noticed that it was
really important there in order in in
the argument because then i was in a
panic because nothing finite index
happens in any of these counter examples
except maybe the third one but certainly
the first two
so so fortunately
i could
repair my point and get the positive
result
if you take z to the k with standard
binary encoding of vectors
and h is a lattice with any index
then you can find it
in a quantum polynomial time uniformly
in the dimension k and the bit
complexity of h
and this is it by the way uh
i did get uniformly in the dimension but
it's already novel when k is two so just
imagine the hidden sub group problem for
z squared just just a two dimensional
lattice where there's only periodicity
in one direction
what do you do then
well there's a difficulty
okay
so
the difficulty
in it in a sense this is a classical
talk not a quantum one the difficulty
the algorithm begins the same way as
shortcut does or at least could
but it knew it requires a new idea for
classical post-processing well a couple
of new ideas
now on the theme of of
challenging hard instances
this is another question where
i thought i realized well it would be
nice if there were hard instances and
which is certainly why shortcutting this
particularly is is especially important
that's what makes it
a cosmic result
i don't know any challenging instances
of hiding functions for this question
much less useful applications to number
theory or cryptography but i'm just
going to go ahead and conjecture that
they exist
yeah so just a basic clarification we
say any index that means any finite
index
well the index is at most no
uh
i'm sorry i have the wrong word this
word index should be rank
oh
any finite index is what is what
shortcut does so the distinction between
unary and binary is the important thing
between the possibility and the
possibility
the important distinction is between
the important distinction is between
this and shortcuttae
where in shortcate of h must have
maximal rank whereas here h can be any
rank
now if you're wondering about
this negative result the important
distinction is
bit polynomial versus pseudo-polynomial
query cost
okay
so
in
my remaining time i want to
uh sketch
uh i want to
get to the
get get
down into the meat of of at least part
of what's going on i mean at least in
outline the what the quantum algorithm
is doing
so
um
so we suppose we have our hiding
function f and there's some lower rank l
and now i take two parameters q and s
which are enormous and and
at least for my theorem
i i need q to be
more enormous than s
okay
now the bit complexity of q and s are
moderate
q and s only take a polynomial number of
bits or you know two to a polynomial in
in in the in the in the input parameter
size n
uh but but you know q q has got to be
bigger than s in order for me to have a
proof
and then i want to start uh start with a
follow-up version of the standard
quantum opening for this hidden sub root
problem and
to some extent any quantum hidden sub
algorithm that anyone has published
wait a minute i've never seen that for
hidden subjects
only for infinite groups but this would
be a standard opening right
i mean you know the the very fact that
you have to prepare these gaussian
states
well see i don't know that i actually
need x i need it for the theory i don't
i don't know that the algorithm needs us
i need s for my proof fine fine
okay
okay
okay
the the
the opening is to
in the finite case start with the
constant pure state on the group right
in the infinite case you need a wide
state right yeah okay okay
so
the state that i choose to work with is
wide in two different ways it's
supported on a big box of size q
and i give it a gaussian taper
okay
the gaussian taper is just for my just
for my proofs not not for the strength
basically it's got to be wide compared
to the periodicity that you're looking
for
um
well
you'd be sunk if it weren't you'd be
back in svp land sure okay
okay okay
but but how how wide it really needs to
be
that's a good question
to which i don't have a complete answer
but i can say you can achieve everything
in polynomial time
okay
[Music]
um
yeah
um
yeah so from the point of view of
heuristic or computer science or better
proof you just would delete this
gaussian and you just have a constant
pure state on on the whole box it would
probably be better
so apply the hiding function f
to this input state in in unitary form
uh you know classical computation but in
superposition
uh and then you get the same
the same sum except also with the input
preserved and the output
and as always happens you you do have to
use on computation to
to censor the scratch work
you're in trouble for the usual reasons
if you don't do that
so then you throw away the output
leaving a uh
an input which is a mixed state
you can assume you can measure it if you
like the algorithm that actually doesn't
measure itself you can say
let's not measure it and say we did
let's throw it away let the janitor
measure anything like that but in
measured form it's easier to express it
as a pure state it's a pure state
supported on the box
okay
and then
still this is sort of the usable you
this is except for notation the usual
script uh
story you apply the quantum fourier
trans operator f
to to this uh partially measured
gaussian state to to measure a fourier
mode
in
the dual
of a cube with opposite sides glued
together so
so you're doing the fourier operator on
a discrete taurus
okay
and what you really want to do at least
conceptually the algorithm doesn't care
so much is you want to rescale by a
factor of q
to interpret this discrete taurus as an
approximation to the continuous torus r
mod z to the k
because
because really morally you're taking a
fourier transform on all of the integers
and the dual of that is a continuous
circle and we're doing the k dimensional
version of that
so then this vector y1 is approximately
a random chosen element of a certain
dual h-sharp
um it's it's a kind of perpendicular but
it's a it's a it's a more complicated
perpendicular as stated here
uh
it's it's uh the official pantry again
or fourier dual to to
z mod z to the k mod the hidden subgroup
it's a subgroup of the taurus and i'm
just going to say more explicitly in
what way h sharp is perpendicular to the
original h
it's those vectors y
such that x dot y is an integer for
every x in h now since h is a set of a
group of integer vectors
uh
this is well-defined mod one it's it's
not a well-defined integer but it's
well-defined mod one
if if the
coordinates of of y are well-defined mod
one which they are
the rank of h is
l
okay
so to to already so you can take two
regimes for this to make it fun you can
take k equals two and l equals one you
can take k equals a and l equals 50 then
both of those are interesting
well if it's equal then it's just
shortcut
yeah except it would be their theorem
not my theory
[Music]
okay
so this sample that you took
has noise for two reasons
it has gaussian noise due to gaussian
blur in dual form and it has noise due
to discretization
the noise is exponentially small if q
and s are exponentially big
but
the feature scale of this h sharp is
also exponentially small
and
i think of a sharp in in
kind of geometrically so here's a
picture here two pictures of of what's
going on
when h sharp is
when when the dimensions are one and two
or sorry when the ambient dimension is
two
if h has full rank like it does on the
left then h sharp is a finite group
and here is a noisy sample it's near one
of the lattice points in h sharp
okay
on the other hand
when
h has lower rank
h sharp has dimension k minus l the
dimension of h sharp is is exactly equal
to the rank deficit
so h sharp is a strike pattern
and it may be disconnected too but if
you can
you can take its connected component and
the connected component
is is
is a certain subgroup h one sharp which
is which already can be some really
complicated looking
diagonal taurus topologically tori are
all the same except for the dimension
but geometrically they can be quite
complicated okay
now the goal is to find h sharp from
random noises from noisy random samples
okay
so in shortcutties if h has full rank so
that h sharp is finite
then
you take the picture on on the left you
say
i
i i we saw this one before already in
short's original paper we saw this
already in short's original paper
you as long as you you work with enough
precision
you you you can find rational
approximations to the coordinates of the
sample y one using the continued
fraction algorithm
um that's that's the advice okay
and uh there's the comment from from
ketea that
if you just have a logarithmic number of
a sample that's logarithmic in the
cardinality of h sharp so log of an
exponential so this is a linear number
of samples
then that'll generate h sharp with high
probability
so for instance in one dimension a big h
is little h times z where a little h is
the period that you're looking for
then then you can succeed with one or
two samples to find what the period h is
as a finite subgroup of the dual circle
okay but you do need the continuing
fraction algorithm
to to denoise the samples
now if the rank is lower
then here's the the the co rank which is
then the dimension of h sharp
then any one coordinate of y one is
uniformly random in the circle
so like here
trying to denoise the first coordinate
of y one well that that's a miserable
failure
it doesn't carry any information at all
trying to denoise the second coordinate
miserable failure
okay so you look at this picture you
think well
well of course you should you should
rotate it and then denoise the
coordinates maybe okay
but here's the thing
uh
if you knew the slope
of these stripes you'd be almost done
actually
so you don't know how much to rotate the
picture in order to denoise with the
continued fraction algorithm
why only almost because you wouldn't
know the offset or
uh if you knew
the slope yeah it would tell you not h
sharp but h1 sharp
so but what it would do is it would
reduce the dimension of the ambient
group to the shortcut case
okay okay
okay all right okay
so uh that doesn't work
but happily the lll lattice algorithm
does work even in high dimensions
uniformly
and uh part of the the
inspiration here is actually from
from early on lll
was interpreted as a
as an approximate or you know
not quite perfect performance but decent
useful performance high dimensional
generalization of the continued fraction
algorithm
so uh
the so a randomly chosen h
but y naught that's a that's exactly an
h chart almost surely densely generates
the connected subgroup h1 sharp
some multiple of it lands in h1 sharp
and if it's uniformly random
then with probability one multiples will
will will make a dense uh subgroup of h
of the connected subgroup of h sharp
so we look for multiples of y one which
is only approximately there that are
near zero
by lifting the dense orbit to a lattice
one dimension higher
so i'm going to write the formulas and
then draw the picture
for a lot of the algorithm
using a bit of outsourcing actually the
algorithm works with just one single
sample with high probability that's not
necessarily the best thing to do but it
works so take a single sample y1
and make a lattice l where the basis in
one one-dimensional war
with the basis of the standard bases e1
through ek
and y1 with a displacement of one over t
in the new
uh dimension where t is another huge
number
well it's longer than huge exponential
of a moderate number
and t has to be
much bigger than
the reciprocal of the feature scale of h
sharp but still much smaller than the
than the source of noise s
so
okay so so all three of these parameters
r t and s or r t and q if you didn't
have s have to be very far apart from
each other but their logarithms can
still be polynomial size
okay so then calculate an ll basis of
short vectors of l
so you'll get uh some
ll basis that way
and the the ll basis is
is
ordered or approximately ordered by
length and we want the first k minus l
plus one vectors
and what those vectors will do
usually with high probability
they'll approximately span the tangent
space of h sharp
at the origin plus the extra dimension
at r
okay
but plus this one extra dimension which
i which i wrote this plus is not mod 2
plus this is direct sum this means that
there's a new dimension
so here's a picture of what's going on
so imagine if you took a perfect sample
rather than a noisy one
then it sweeps out a dense orbit which
doesn't look like useful computational
geometry but if you just displace the
generate the vector generator in the new
dimension and then take multiples
then then the dense subgroup can resolve
to a discrete lattice in the next
dimension
okay
nonetheless in in this three-dimensional
case
the first two short vectors
if if you make the parameters extreme
enough will be very short and we'll map
out they'll be tangent they'll be very
close to the origin and they'll be
tangent to h sharp and tangent to the
new direction
so you get a you get a useful little
basis there
okay
um
and so you have to use an estimate for
the feature scale to to to separate out
the
the the useful ll short vectors from
from the rest of the from from the rest
of the lol bases okay
[Music]
okay so we we take the vectors we wanted
the the the tiny ones that will show us
the direction of h sharp points
and then you make a matrix and now
we want something to denoise and you
can't denoise these individual vectors
separately
but you can put this in
cref form column reduced echelon form
if you think of them as column vectors
by inverting
some square sub matrix a
okay
and if you could trust your choice of a
then
actually
the
the uh
the noiseless versions of of
the vectors after the change of bases or
um i guess a inverse b is what it would
be or
uh or b a inverse one of those two
uh or i wrote a i guess a inverse b
those would be things that you can
denoise with the continued fraction
algorithm well i'm going to say that in
a second anyway
but we want a good choice of a we want
an a
that we can invert for a good reason
that it's noiseless version has an
inverse
not
not a matrix that's singular
just and it should have been singular
but it's non-singular just because of
noise
okay
um
so the you there's a greedy pursuit
algorithm
uh using the koshibane formula which is
this kind of nifty higher dimensional
pythagorean theorem
you can strike one row at a time from
matrix b to to to maximize this
determinant
using a greedy algorithm and find a
square matrix that'll be
better than average and in particular
good enough for for inversion purposes
okay so then then the entries of a
inverse b are approximate rational
numbers that you can denoise with the
continued fraction algorithm
so that leads yields a rational basis
for
h-sharp
plus the new direction
and i'm writing this as hr perp
so what do i mean by hr perp
that's the perpendicular
of the vector subspace hr that's spanned
by the hidden subgroup that you have
okay
well one once you have that then you
know the direction that h points if you
know the direction that h sharp points
that you know the direction of h itself
point so that you don't know h itself
so this is where we stand
okay
we took a noisy sample we used lll we
denoised the result and we found a
rational basis
for
for the real vector space yes
summation over a so
what's the range of k
all
largest square sub-matrices
if you think about it
so
this this cool fact due to koshi
you know if you take a a right
uh tetrahedron
then there's the area formula a squared
plus c squared plus a squared plus b
squared with c squared equals d squared
for the areas of the four triangle sides
okay
so
because this koshibani is is a
maximal generalization of that for any
pair of dimensions
you take the rectilinear projections of
of of any flat uh l
shape that's lower dimensional and you
take the sum of the squares and you get
the square of the volume of the result
this is an algebraic form of that of
that of that
this would also
uh apply to fermions right this tells
you why fermionic amplitude will be
normalized
anyway
yeah
okay but the relevant point is that see
what's really going on here is this
suppose you're in low dimensions and you
just want a rational number
to describe
in just two dimensions the slope of that
line
so you have two numbers for a vector
first coordinate second coordinate
you want to divide the smaller
coordinate by the larger coordinate
because if you make the ratio top heavy
you could be dividing by zero
except for noise
that's what you're trying to avoid
and in high dimensions it takes it
actually takes a strategy
to to be able to get stable ratios
and that's you you need to invert by a
good square sub matrix then you can turn
this into a greedy algorithm to find one
okay so to finish the algorithm we can
use smith normal form
to
find a rational basis for to convert the
rational bases to an integral basis not
for the original h1
but to all integer vectors
that lie in the in the real or rational
span of the original h
okay so h1 is bigger than h
okay
so
the original h has finite index in this
rational closure h1 so then you can
here's where i'm outsourcing we can now
finish the whole algorithm by using
standard shortcut to find h
okay
all right so that's the whole algorithm
and i'll just finish with open
problems um
to keep the proof tidy i only use one
sample not just in the talk but in the
paper
you you have to be better off
it's clear that you'd be better off with
more than one sample
and
and moreover with a combined algorithm
that does the short stage together
together with the new stage
to together with the recovery from
deficient rank
how many samples it's not so clear
it depends on the on the it's a it gives
you a trade-off between classical and
quantum resources
and that also
that that also uh
depends on the how to do that trade-off
depends on the specific complexity of
the hiding function and for that well it
would be nice to have a challenging
index so that's the second open problem
is there a challenging hiding function
[Music]
and just to give the definition
challenging means
that
if you can look at the algorithm to
compute f itself that doesn't give you
some simple way to get the periodicity
more correct more directly
um
and so finally i i
the whole theme of my paper is the
discrete group case but there's a very
very interesting effect quite important
other paper eisendrager hallgren
cateavan song
that looks at the hidden subgroup
problem
on r to the k
for a certain topological or analytic
definition of a continuous hiding
function but where again the hidden
subgroup h has maximal rank and
this is i'm not even sure how to call
this open how open this really is i i
haven't done the work but i could just
kind of see it coming but there really
should be a mutual generalization of the
two algorithms for the case when h has
lower rank
so i'll stop there
well thanks a lot so
this
seems like a very very nice counterpart
to you know the old question that i
mentioned of you know is there a
challenging hiding function for simon's
problem
yeah
okay
all right it's not i can't i was gonna i
i was wondering if if
if finding a challenging hype function
for simons would find it challenging
that's not i don't see a reduction yeah
unfortunately
i i
i guess
well you just call me biased but i
you know
really really the way that this has been
important for the real world is for the
post-spawn photography
project
i mean the whole topic of the hidden
problem has been the most important for
that
um and
and
somehow i was hoping for some something
that looked like algorithmic number
theory or photography
[Music]
but
yeah i guess you could say the same as
for assignments but yeah yeah
yeah
all right any uh questions
i'll show you guys
actually ended early
any questions anyone
what's left for you to do
to have your well
um
so uh
well i need to
i mean i have one subsection left to
right and i i wanted to do something for
virtually abelian groups
which which are all of the same
there's
it's not as it it's not as interesting a
result to present but i i wanted to also
do something for for virtually a billion
infinite groups that means that a finite
index sub group is a billion which are
all going to be at the same level as a
viewing hidden shift or dihedral hidden
subgroup
and then
but
well i don't know i mean maybe maybe the
paper is long longer than it should be
but the paper is what it is
no no no no no no no no no no no it's
just it's just that the ideas for the
ego didn't sound rude
you can think of a virtually union
group as being
similar enough to a finite digital group
that the same ideas apply that's that's
really what needs to be said in that
section
um other other questions
well if not then what's that greg again